Bonjour à tous!
Aujourd'hui on va parler d'une énigme
à un million de dollars.
Vous savez, un de ces sept problèmes
de mathématiques
pour lesquels l'institut Clay
a décidé d'offrir une récompense
à celui ou celle qui en trouverait
une solution.
Le problème d'aujourd'hui est intéressant
car il est à la frontière entre
les mathématiques et l'informatique
et il est parfois considéré comme
le plus simple des sept.
Alors, le plus simple, pas forcément
à résoudre mais du moins à expliquer,
car il concerne en quelque sorte
la rapidité des algorithmes
qui sont utilisés par nos ordinateurs.
Commençons par un problème très simple,
imaginons que je vous donne
une liste de nombres
et que je vous demande de trouver
le plus petit nombre de cette liste,
son minimum.
Pas très compliqué, vous prenez
un bout de papier
vous parcourez la liste et sur le papier
vous gardez trace
du plus petit nombre que vous avez croisé
pour l'instant,
vous mettez à jour si vous en trouvez
un plus petit
et une fois arrivé à la fin de la liste,
eh bien vous avez la certitude d'avoir
sur votre bout de papier le minimum
de cette liste.
Alors, l'air de rien, quand on fait ça
on applique un algorithme
c'est à dire une procédure bien définie
qui résout un problème donné
en prenant en entrée, ici:
la liste de nombre,
et en fournissant une sortie:
le plus petit nombre de cette liste.
Quand on met au point un algorithme
pour effectuer une certaine tâche,
on va souvent s'intéresser à sa rapidité,
combien de temps va-t-il lui falloir
pour réaliser le job?
On pourrait la mesurer de différentes façons,
par exemple avec un chronomètre,
mais ça va évidemment dépendre
de la puissance de la machine
sur laquelle on le fait tourner.
Alors une autre façon de quantifier
la rapidité d'un algorithme,
c'est de compter combien d'opérations
élémentaires il doit effectuer.
Dans notre cas, on voit que
pour chaque nombre de la liste,
il faut le lire pour le comparer
au plus petit qu'on ait trouvé jusqu'ici,
on va dire que faire cette comparaison
c'est une opération.
Alors évidemment s'il y a 10 nombres
dans ma liste
je vais devoir faire 10 opérations,
100 nombres: 100 opérations
1000 nombres: 1000 opérations etc.
De façon générale, avec cet algorithme
s'il y a N nombre dans la liste
il me faudra faire N opérations
élémentaires pour l'appliquer.
Considérons maintenant un problème
un peu différent,
il ne s'agit plus de trouver
le plus petit nombre de la liste
mais de la classer par ordre croissant.
C'est plus compliqué mais on peut facilement
imaginer un algorithme qui le fait.
Puisqu'on sait trouver le minimum d'une liste
grâce à l'algorithme précédent,
on n'a qu'à le chercher
et le sortir de la liste.
Et puis ensuite recommencer
sur la liste restante,
trouver son minimum, le sortir,
puis à nouveau etc.
C'est juste un peu plus long puisqu'il va
falloir appliquer plein de fois
l'algorithme de recherche du
plus petit nombre d'une liste.
On peut calculer que pour faire ça avec
10 nombres dans la liste
il me faudra au total une cinquantaine
d'opérations élémentaires,
avec 100 nombres il faudra 5 000 opérations
et avec 1 000 nombres, environ 500 000.
Vous voyez que la situation de
cet algorithme de tri
est assez différente de celle de l'algorithme
de recherche d'un minimum,
le nombre d'opérations nécessaires
augmente beaucoup plus quand la taille
de la liste augmente.
Si N est la taille de la liste, le nombre
d'opérations nécessaires pour la trier
avec cet algorithme est en gros (N au carré) /2
et ça change beaucoup de choses,
vous voyez que si je multiplie
la taille de la liste par 10,
trouver le minimum prendra 10 fois
plus de temps,
mais en faire le tri prendra
100 fois plus de temps.
Quand on veut traiter beaucoup de données
avec un ordinateur,
cette différence va se faire sentir.
Cette question du nombre d'opérations
nécessaire
on se la pose évidemment chaque fois
que l'on imagine
un nouvel algorithme pour résoudre
un problème donné.
On essaye d'estimer comment
le nombre d'opérations
va croître quand on augmente la taille
du problème
c'est-à-dire la taille des données en entrée.
On note toujours traditionnellement
N cette taille,
pour la recherche de minimum, le nombre
d'opérations est proportionnelle à N,
pour la méthode de tri que je vous ai présentée,
il est proportionnel à N au carré .
Cette notion là c'est ce qu'on appelle
la "complexité" de l'algorithme.
Alors attention hein, car ce terme
de complexité peut être un peu trompeur.
La complexité ça ne mesure pas
à quel point l'algorithme est
difficile à comprendre ou à programmer
mais de quelle façon le temps de calcul
va augmenter quand on augmente
la taille du problème.
Pour ma recherche de minimum, la complexité
est proportionnelle à N, la taille de la liste,
on dit que la complexité est linéaire.
Pour mon algorithme de tri elle est
proportionnelle à N²,
on parle de complexité quadratique,
Comme vous pouvez vous en douter,
ces questions de complexité
sont très importantes pour toutes
les applications pratiques
où on a besoin d'algorithmes,
que l'on parle de gestion de données,
de graphisme, de calcul scientifique,
de jeux vidéo.
Heureusement grâce à l'inventivité
des chercheurs,
on découvre régulièrement des algorithmes
de plus en plus rapides pour résoudre
un problème donné.
Reprenons le problème du tri
d'une liste de nombres,
la méthode que je vous ai présentée,
qu'on peut appeler l'algorithme naïf,
vous sentez peut-être qu'elle n'est
pas forcément hyper maligne,
on parcourt la liste pour trouver
le plus petit élément,
puis ont la re-parcourt pour trouver le 2ème
plus petit, puis à nouveau etc,
On est amené à refaire plusieurs fois
quasiment la même chose.
Intuitivement on se dit qu'il doit y avoir
moyen de gagner du temps
en exploitant mieux l'information.
Eh bien oui, c'est possible, on connaît
aujourd'hui
plusieurs algorithmes de tri dont
la complexité n'est pas proportionnelle à N²
mais à N fois logarithme de N: N x log (N)
et ça fait une sacrée différence,
ça veut dire que, pour une liste
de 10 nombres,
il ne vous faudra, par exemple,
qu'une trentaine d'opérations,
pour 100 nombres: environ 600 opérations
et seulement 10 000 opérations
pour trier une liste de 1000 nombres.
C'est bien mieux que mon algorithme naïf
et plus on augmente la taille de la liste
plus le gain est important.
Bien, donc pour trier une liste de nombre
par ordre croissant
il faut faire attention au choix
de l'algorithme,
certains ont une complexité plus faible
que d'autres
et demanderont donc moins d'opérations,
et quand on trie une grande liste,
eh bien ça peut faire une vraie différence.
Malgré tout il y a une chose remarquable,
si au lieu de vous demander
de trier une grande liste à la main
je vous la donne
et je vous demande juste de vérifier
si, oui ou non, elle est déjà triée
par ordre croissant
et bien là ça devient beaucoup plus facile,
il vous suffit de parcourir les nombres
les uns après les autres
et de vérifier qu'ils sont
correctement rangés
jusqu'à ce que vous repériez un problème
ou que vous arriviez au bout de la liste.
Pour une liste de longueur N,
il suffit de N étapes
pour faire cette vérification, c'est tout.
En algorithmique trouver la solution
d'un problème
et vérifier une proposition de solution,
ce sont deux choses différentes
et c'est une distinction qu'on retrouve
dans plein de situations.
Prenons un cas bien connu: le sudoku.
Résoudre un sudoku, ça peut prendre
pas mal de temps
et il y en a des plus ou moins compliqués.
Par contre vérifier qu'une grille de sudoku
a été bien remplie,
bah c'est très simple, on regarde
chaque ligne, chaque colonne, chaque carré,
pour s'assurer que tout est OK.
Quelle que soit la difficulté du sudoku,
vérifier que la solution est la bonne
c'est toujours très rapide.
Voici un autre problème du même genre
qui a une grande importance pratique
et théorique,
on l'appelle "le problème du sac à dos".
Imaginez que vous soyez un gangster
qui fait un casse dans un magasin
à l'intérieur duquel il y à des objets
qui ont tous une valeur et un poids.
Vous ne pouvez porter disons que 50 kg
dans votre sac à dos,
mais votre patron, le chef de la mafia,
vous a ordonné de ramener
pour au moins 10 000 euros de marchandises.
La question qui se pose c'est:
étant donné les objets qui sont là,
est-ce que c'est possible de répondre
à la demande?
Alors ça paraît simple comme problème
mais ça ne l'est pas du tout
quand il commence à y avoir beaucoup d'objets.
Un algorithme un peu bourrin pour tenter
de répondre à cette question,
c'est d'essayer toutes les combinaisons
possibles.
C'est ce qu'on appelle une méthode
"par force brute",
si on a N objets devant soi
et que chaque objet,
on peut soit le prendre
soit ne pas le prendre,
ça veut dire qu'il y a au total
2 puissance N combinaisons possibles.
On peut très bien toutes les essayer
jusqu'à tomber
sur une sélection d'objets qui, à la fois
rentre dans le sac à dos
et permette de dépasser 10 000 euros.
Ou alors on peut se retrouver à les avoir
toutes testées
et pouvoir conclure avec certitude
que ce n'est pas possible.
Le souci c'est que s'il y a 2 puissances N
combinaisons à tester,
vous voyez que ça augmente très vite,
avec 10 objets c'est 1024 possibilités,
avec 20 il y en a environ un million,
avec 60 objets un milliard de milliards,
et avec 300 objets il y a plus de
combinaisons possibles
que d'atomes dans l'univers visible
et vous voyez que c'est beaucoup plus
critique que dans la question du tri,
quand on augmente le nombre d'objets,
la complexité,
le nombre d'opérations nécessaires
n'augmente pas proportionnellement
à N ou N au carré,
elle augmente proportionnellement
à 2 puissance N,
ont dit que la complexité est exponentielle,
donc trouver une solution
au problème du sac à dos
par cette méthode bourrin
c'est très très long,
Par contre, comme pour le sudoku, vérifier
si une proposition de solution fonctionne
eh ben, c'est très simple!
Il suffit d'additionner les poids
des objets sélectionnés
pour vérifier qu'on est sous la limite,
ça fait N opérations,
puis additionner les valeurs
pour vérifier qu'on est au-delà
de l'objectif, encore N opérations.
Pour trouver la solution la complexité
est exponentielle,
pour vérifier une solution elle est linéaire,
proportionnelle à N
ça n'est pas du tout la même histoire.
Il y à un autre problème bien connu
pour lequel on a cette situation
et qui a une très grande
importance pratique
c'est le problème de la décomposition
des nombres en facteurs premiers.
Imaginons que je vous donne un nombre entier,
disons 30,
et que je vous demande de le décomposer
en un produit de nombres premiers.
Il n'y a qu'une façon de le faire,
il suffit de la trouver,
alors un peu de réflexion et vous allez
constater que c'est 2 fois 3 fois 5.
Bien, maintenant on complique, décomposer
moi 10 241
et là, ça devient pénible, il faut essayer
plein de divisions
et la bonne réponse c'est 7 x 7 x 11 x 19,
c'est pas très simple d'y arriver
par tâtonnement,
et la façon de faire c'est en gros d'essayer
de diviser par tous les nombres
qui sont plus petits
et ça prend du temps, mais par contre
à vérifier,
une fois que je vous ai donné la réponse,
bah ça va très vite,
il suffit de faire la multiplication
et plus les facteurs premiers sont grands
plus la différence
entre "trouver "et "vérifier" est flagrante.
Si je prend 56 millions 475 mille 871,
essayez de trouver sa décomposition
en facteurs premiers, eh bien, bon courage!
Parce que c'est 7247 fois 7793!
et pour des produits de nombres premiers
très grands, c'est encore pire!
Pour décomposer de façon naïve un nombre
de taille N
c'est-à-dire qui s'écrit avec N chiffres
il va vous falloir quelque chose comme
10 puissance N opérations.
Donc, quand la taille du nombre augmente,
le temps de calcul grimpe très très vite,
de façon exponentielle, et pour des nombres
suffisamment grands
ça devient impossible en pratique,
même avec un algorithme meilleur
et une puissance de calcul énorme
à disposition.
Cette difficulté à trouver la décomposition
en facteurs premiers d'un nombre très grand,
elle est à la base de l'efficacité
du protocole de sécurité qu'on appelle RSA.
Il s'agit d'une technique de chiffrement
des données
qui est largement utilisée aujourd'hui
pour protéger des communications
ou des transactions sur internet notamment.
J'en ai parlé dans mon épisode
sur les codes secrets
et si on savait décomposé des grands nombres
de façon rapide
ça mettrait à mal ces protocoles
de sécurité,
donc, de façon un peu surprenante,
on est content
que ce problème en particulier
soit difficile à résoudre.
Pour y voir clair dans tous ces algorithmes
et leur complexité,
les chercheurs en informatique théorique
ont élaboré une classification
qui permet de faire en quelque sorte
de la "zoologie" des algorithmes,
c'est ce qu'on appelle "les classes
de complexité" des problèmes.
Si pour un certa in problème vous possédez
un algorithme dont la complexité
est proportionnelle à N ou N²,
N puissance 7,54 ou N puissance n'importe quoi
on dit que ce problème appartient
à la classe "P".
"P" ça veut dire polynomial et c'est
pour désigner
toutes les expressions de la forme
N puissance quelque chose,
et cette classe comprend aussi toutes
les complexités
qui mélangent avec des logarithmes comme
par exemple N² fois logarithme de N.
Pour caricaturer on pourrait dire
que cette classe regroupe
tous les problèmes "faciles" ou "rapides"
à résoudre,
on dit aussi qu'on peut les résoudre
"en temps polynomial".
Maintenant, on l'a vu, il existe
certains problèmes
pour lesquels le meilleur algorithme
dont on dispose
n'est pas polynomial, il peut être
par exemple exponentiel
comme quand un algorithme à une complexité
de 2 puissances N.
Ce sont des problèmes qu'on pourrait
dire "difficiles à résoudre"
mais parmi tous ces problèmes difficiles,
il en existe certains
dont on a vu qu'ils étaient
faciles à vérifier
c'est à dire que la complexité
de la vérification est polynomiale,
même souvent linéaire, comme dans le problème
du sac à dos,
ces problèmes-là en particulier,
qui sont faciles à vérifier,
on leur attribue une classe particulière
qu'on appelle la classe "NP".
Attention, petit piège, "NP" ne veut pas
dire "Non polynomial"
mais "Non déterministe polynomial",
il y a une définition technique mais ça traduit
en gros cette idée de facile à vérifier.
Maintenant parmi ces problèmes
faciles à vérifier,
et ben on trouve, notamment ceux
qui sont aussi faciles à résoudre,
bah oui, si c'est facile à résoudre,
c'est facile à vérifier,
ça veut dire que la classe P est en fait,
contenue dans la classe NP.
Bon ça sera plus clair avec un dessin.
Ici on va représenter l'ensemble des problèmes
NP qui sont faciles à vérifier,
et ici les problèmes P qui sont faciles
à résoudre
mais, du coup, aussi facile à vérifier.
Trier une liste sera là par exemple
dans les problèmes P,
mais le problème du sac à dos serait ici
dans les problèmes NP qui ne sont pas P
puisque une solution est facile à vérifier
mais que la trouver
demande un algorithme de complexité
exponentielle.
Bien sûr il existe des problèmes
qui ne sont même pas NP,
des problèmes ou même vérifier
une solution est difficile,
par exemple tous les problèmes
où on cherche le meilleur mouvement
à faire aux échecs ou au go.
Le point essentiel dans cette classification
c'est qu'elle est évolutive.
Ben oui, pour classer un problème on se base
sur le meilleur algorithme
dont on dispose pour le résoudre
donc on peut parfaitement imaginer
qu'à un moment donné
le meilleur algorithme qu'on connaisse
soit de complexité exponentielle
ce qui nous amène à classer ce problème
dans la classe NP par exemple,
et puis qu'un jour, un petit malin découvre
un algorithme de complexité polynomiale
qui résout aussi le problème montrant
qu'en fait il appartient à la classe P .
Alors c'est assez rare tout de même
mais un exemple récent,
c'est ce qu'on appelle les tests de primalité.
En gros étant donné un nombre entier
il s'agit de répondre à la question:
est-ce que oui ou non,
c'est un nombre premier?
Ça n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
que de décomposer un nombre
en facteurs premiers,
c'est une question un peu plus limitée,
juste de savoir s'il est premier ou pas.
Eh bien jusqu'à une période récente
le meilleur algorithme dont on disposait
était de complexité exponentielle,
jusqu'à ce qu'en 2002 trois
chercheurs indiens
découvrent un algorithme polynomial
permettant de répondre à cette question.
Cet algorithme qu'on appelle AKS,
de leurs initiales,
a une complexité en N puissance 12,
où comme tout à l'heure N désigne
la taille du problème
c'est à dire le nombre de chiffres
nécessaires
pour écrire le nombre
qu'on souhaite tester.
Assez rapidement, leur algorithme
a même été amélioré
en une version de complexité N puissance 6,
alors ça fait toujours beaucoup d'opérations,
ça reste un degré de complexité assez élevé,
mais c'est polynomial puisque
c'est N puissance quelque chose.
Ça montre donc que le problème de déterminer
si un nombre est premier ou pas,
c'est un problème de la classe P, avant on
ne pensait pas que c'était le cas.
Ce qu'on peut s'imaginer c'est qu'au fur
et à mesure des progrès réalisés
par les chercheurs en algorithmique,
la classe P va comme ça grossir
progressivement à force de trouver
des algorithmes polynomiaux
pour des problèmes pour lesquels
on en avait pas.
Donc les frontières vont bouger, la question
qu'on peut se poser maintenant
c'est: jusqu'où ça va aller?
Est ce qu'il existe des problèmes NP
pour lesquelles il est strictement
impossible
de trouver un algorithme polynomial?
Dans ce cas-là ça signifierait
que la classe NP serait vraiment
différente de la classe P.
Ou bien au contraire est-ce que
pour chaque problème NP,
il existe en fait quelque part
un algorithme polynomial
qu'il suffirait de trouver?
Auquel cas P et NP ne seraient en fait
qu'une seule et même classe.
Si c'était vrai, ça signifie que
tout problème qui se vérifie
en temps polynomial peut, en principe,
se résoudre aussi en temps polynomial.
Ce serait assez extraordinaire,
ça signifierait en gros
que tout problème qui est facile à vérifier
est d'une façon ou d'une autre
facile à résoudre.
Et bien c'est cette question
qui constitue
l'un des fameux 7 problèmes à
un million de dollars,
est-ce que la classe P et la classe NP
sont en fait une seule et même classe?
Est-ce que P = NP?
Une question que vous vous posez
peut-être c'est:
comment est-ce qu'on peut aborder
un tel problème?
Imaginons qu'on essaye de démontrer
que P est différent de NP.
Je vous l'ai dis, pour ça il faudrait trouver
un problème NP, un seul,
et démontrer que quoi qu'on fasse,
pour celui ci,
il est mathématiquement impossible
de trouver un algorithme polynomial.
C'est toujours assez difficile ce genre
de démonstration,
comment démontrer une impossibilité
de faire quelque chose?
Eh bien il existe certaines méthodes
et je vais vous l'illustrer avec
un cas très simpliste.
Reprenons le problème de trier
une liste de nombres,
s'il y a N nombres vous sentez bien
qu'il n'est pas possible
de le faire en moins de N étapes,
il faut au moins aller lire une fois
chaque nombre,
donc il sera toujours impossible de trouver
un algorithme
qui trie la liste en, par exemple
racine de N étapes.
On a donc un argument logique qui prouve que,
pour ce problème,
quoi qu'on fasse, la complexité
ne peut pas
descendre en dessous d'un certain seuil.
Et même, avec une analyse un peu plus fine,
on pourrait montrer
qu'on ne peut jamais faire mieux
que N logarithme de N.
Pour un algorithme de tri.
démontrer comme ça qu'on ne peut pas
aller en dessous d'une certaine limite,
ça s'appelle trouver une "borne inférieure"
et c'est compliqué en général, mais
c'est possible dans certains cas.
Ce qu'il faudrait donc pour prouver que
P est différent de NP,
c'est identifier un problème pour lequel
on puisse trouver une borne inférieure
qui prouve qu'aucun algorithme polynomial
ne pourra jamais le résoudre.
Mais bon, à ce jour, personne n'a jamais
réussi sur aucun problème NP,
et la raison c'est peut-être parce
qu'en fait c'est faut,
peut-être que pour tous les problèmes NP
il existe un algorithme polynomial
et que donc P = NP.
Alors, si c'est ça, comment est-ce qu'on peut
le démontrer?
Est-ce qu'il faut trouver explicitement
un algorithme polynomial
pour tous les problèmes NP qu'on connaît?
C'est dur parce que déjà il y en a
une infinité,
et on peut toujours en inventer des nouveaux,
donc on ne sera jamais au bout de la tâche.
Heureusement il existe des problèmes NP
particuliers
qui sont en quelque sorte universels
et permettraient de tout résoudre d'un coup.
Le plus universel de ces problèmes c'est
celui qu'on appelle SAT.
Je vous explique dans une minute
en quoi il consiste,
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
n'importe quel problème NP peut être
ramené au problème SAT.
En quelque sorte le problème SAT
les contient tous,
ça veut dire que si vous saviez résoudre
SAT en temps polynomial
vous sauriez résoudre tous les problèmes
NP en temps polynomial.
Magique non?
C'est un peu l'équivalent de "l'anneau
unique pour les gouverner tous".
Alors qu'est ce que c'est que
ce fameux problème SAT?
Eh bien, à nouveau prenons une illustration,
imaginez un club privé avec un certain
nombre de membres
qui décident de lancer une procédure de
recrutement pour admettre des nouveaux.
Il y a un certain nombre de candidats
qui postulent,
on va leur mettre des numéros,
et pour décider qui pourra entrer,
chaque membre actuel a le droit
à UNE exigence,
alors une exigence c'est quoi?
C'est soit un veto, par exemple:
"je refuse que le candidat 42"
soit admis,
soit le contraire d'un veto:
"j'exige que le candidat 17" soit admis.
Chaque membre formule comme ça
une exigence de recrutement
et il n'y a aucune limitation de place,
on peut admettre autant de nouveaux qu'on veut.
Le souci vous le voyez c'est qu'il n'est
pas toujours possible
de trouver une solution qui satisfasse
tout le monde.
Si par exemple un membre exige l'admission
du candidat 17
et qu'un autre membre met son veto
sur le candidat 17, eh ben on est coincé!
La question à laquelle on cherche à répondre
c'est donc:
"étant donné la liste des exigences
de chaque membre,
est ce qu'il existe oui ou non, une solution
pour les satisfaire tous? "
On dit que c'est un problème
de satisfaisabilité: SAT.
Quand chaque membre n'a qu'une exigence
c'est facile de répondre à cette question.
Soit il y à une contradiction comme celle
que je viens de mentionner,
deux membres sont en conflit sur un candidat
et c'est mort pour satisfaire tout le monde.
Soit il n'y a pas de conflit direct
et on sait qu'il existe toujours une solution
et même certainement plusieurs.
Ce problème-ci de dire s'il existe
une solution
quand chaque membre n'a qu'une exigence
on l'appelle 1-SAT
et, comme on vient de voir,
il est assez facile.
Alors compliquons un peu, maintenant
chaque membre doit formuler 2 exigences
et ce qu'on essaye de lui garantir
c'est que au moins une des deux
sera satisfaite,
alors peut-être les deux,
mais au moins une.
Alors ça c'est bien, ça peut permettre
de résoudre des blocages
si deux membres sont en conflit
sur un candidat,
on peut aller voir l'autre exigence
de l'un ou de l'autre.
Pour autant le problème n'a pas toujours
de solution non plus,
et déterminer s'il en a une ou pas
c'est le problème qu'on appelle 2-SAT
et il n'est pas très compliqué non plus.
Maintenant je vais généraliser, chaque membre
formule un certain nombre d'exigences,
pas le même nombre pour chaque,
et on veut garantir
que chaque membre en aura au moins une
de satisfaite.
Question toujours donc: "pour une liste
d'exigences données par chacun des membres
est ce qu'il existe une solution? "
Eh bien c'est ça en toute généralité
qu'on appelle le problème SAT.
Pour résoudre le problème soit il faudrait
donc un algorithme qui,
étant donnée une liste d'exigences
de chaque membre,
dit si, oui ou non, il y à
une solution possible.
Aujourd'hui on ne sait pas faire ça
en temps polynomial,
ça n'est donc pas a priori un problème P,
par contre si je vous fais une suggestion
de solutions
c'est-à-dire une liste de membres
que je vous propose d'admettre,
eh bien c'est très facile
et rapide de vérifier
que cette liste répond aux critères ou pas,
vous prenez chaque membre et vous
vous assurez
qu'au moins une de ces exigences
est satisfaite, et vous passez au suivant.
C'est super rapide, le problème SAT
est donc un problème NP facile à vérifier,
évidemment là je vous ai présenté une forme
imagée avec mon histoire de club privé,
mais, pour les connaisseurs, le problème
SAT est en fait
un problème abstrait de satisfaction
de formule en logique booléenne,
et ce qui fait l'importance du problème SAT,
c'est que dans les années 70,
deux informaticiens, Cook et Levin,
ont montré
que ce problème est tellement générique
que n'importe quel problème NP peut être
ramené au problème SAT.
Donc si vous résolvez le problème SAT
en temps polynomial
ça vous permet de résoudre n'importe quel
problème NP en temps polynomial.
Cette propriété ça porte un nom, on dit
que le problème SAT est "NP-complet"
et des problèmes NP-complets comme SAT,
il en existe en fait un certain nombre.
Suite aux travaux de Cook et Levin,
plusieurs autres problèmes NP-complets
ont été identifiés
et ils forment donc une classe de complexité
à l'intérieur de l'ensemble NP,
dans cette classe, à part SAT on trouve
notamment le problème du sac à dos,
le sudoku, et le problème qu'on appelle
du voyageur de commerce.
Et donc le truc un peu magique c'est que
si vous prenez un de ces problèmes NP-complets,
un seul, SAT ou un autre,
et que vous trouvez un algorithme
polynomial pour le résoudre
vous montrez qu'il est dans P mais puisque
tous les problèmes NP peuvent s'y ramener,
eh bien par contagion en quelque sorte,
vous montrez
que tous les problèmes NP sont dans P
et donc que "P = NP".
Bingo, à vous le million!
Alors à ce jour on ne sait pas si P = NP
ou si P est différent de NP
et vous voyez que, dans les deux cas,
le démontrer peut se faire d'une façon
qui semble simple
ou du moins en ne travaillant
que sur un seul problème.
Soit vous trouvez un problème NP
dont vous démontrez
qu'il ne sera jamais P grâce
à une borne inférieure,
soit vous prenez un problème NP-complet
pour lequel vous trouvez
un algorithme de complexité polynomiale.
Et de fait, une des propriétés
assez attirante de cette question
est-ce que P égale NP, bah c'est
qu'on a l'impression
que c'est à la portée de n'importe qui,
chercher un algorithme polynomial
pour résoudre par exemple le problème
du sac à dos, bah y'a pas besoin
de concepts de math très compliqués
à mobiliser, il n'y a qu'à essayer.
Une apparence trompeuse de facilité
et pourtant
parmi les 7 problèmes à un million
de dollars,
c'est probablement celui dont la résolution
pourrait avoir
le plus de conséquences pratiques.
Imaginez que quelqu'un trouve effectivement
que P = NP
et que cette démonstration fournisse
explicitement un algorithme polynomial
pour n'importe quel problème NP,
ça veut dire notamment qu'on pourrait
factoriser des grands nombres
en temps polynomial et donc craquer
les chiffrements RSA
qui à l'heure actuelle protègent pas mal
de communications et transactions sur internet.
Sinon on pourrait aussi résoudre
en temps polynomial
le problème du repliement des protéines,
ce qui permettrait peut-être de trouver
des molécules pour soigner
tout un tas de maladies comme,
disons, le cancer.
Bref si P = NP ça peut être révolutionnaire,
si ça se trouve c'est vous qui allez le
montrer en trouvant un algorithme polynomial
pour le problème du sac à dos,
à vous le million de dollars du prix
et puis surtout les centaines de milliards
que vous allez pouvoir vous faire
en piratant toutes les transactions mondiales,
enfin bon, vous emballez pas trop hein!
Il y a deux trucs importants
pour modérer cet espoir.
Le premier c'est que même si P = NP
et qu'on trouve des algorithmes polynomiaux,
ça ne veut pas dire qu'en pratique
ils seront rapides,
un algorithme de complexité
N puissance 7458
est techniquement polynomial
mais inutilisable en pratique,
donc il se pourrait qu'une telle
démonstration n'ait
que des conséquences théoriques
et puis surtout je vais certainement doucher
vos espoirs restants,
mais il est assez peu probable
que tout ça soit vrai,
la plupart des chercheurs pensent que P
est en fait différent de NP
et que donc vous ne trouverez
pas d'algorithme polynomial
pour le problème du sac à dos.
Un des chercheurs du domaine, William Gasarch
s'amuse à faire régulièrement des sondages
pour voir ce que pensent les mathématiciens
de la question: est-ce que P égal à NP?
En 2002, 61% pensaient que c'était faux
et donc P est différent de NP.
En 2012 ce pourcentage était monté à 83% .
Et en 2019 à 88%
et encore, si on restreint le sondage
aux experts du domaine
ils sont 99 % à estimer
que P est différent de NP.
Comme le disait un de ces chercheurs,
les gens qui pensent que P = NP
sont comme ceux qui veulent encore croire
qu'Elvis Presley est vivant.
Malgré tout, comme beaucoup de conjectures
en mathématiques,
si la plupart des chercheurs semblent
d'accord sur le résultat
ça n'est pas pour autant
qu'on sait le démontrer
et rien ne dit qu'on arrivera
à le faire un jour.
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
Si cet épisode vous a plu
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner,
mettre un pouce, la cloche tout ça.
Si vous avez des questions techniques
j'ai écrit un billet de blog
qui accompagne la vidéo.
Je mets le lien dans la description
et je donne quelques compléments,
et je précise aussi quelques approximations
que j'ai dû faire.
sinon les actualités de la chaîne ça se passe
sur facebook et twitter.
Et puis moi je vous dis à très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo, à bientôt!
–Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -